[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everybody would just sort of stay
in room be out of momentum but that
didn't happen
hello everybody I am thrilled to be here
I am thrilled to be back at JS comp and
thrilled that J's conf itself is back I
was so sad I was so sad when it had to
shut down and I'm so glad that it is
back but before we get started and is
very important that the first order of
business is that I take a crowd selfie
because if I don't take a selfie with
you did this even really happen all
right
important things out of the way I can
just wing it from now I'm Laurie vos I
am the the co-founder of NPM Inc my
title is CEO but don't take that too
seriously they had to give me a title
and that one happened to be unoccupied
what I am is a web developer I've been a
web developer for 22 years now and I
really really care about web development
and today I'm going to be talking to you
about what's going on in the world of
JavaScript because NPM has a lot of
information about what's going on in the
world of JavaScript we have real usage
numbers not just hype about you know
what you should use this is what you're
actually using and we know and we're
gonna share it with you with the hope
that it'll help you make technical
decisions if you know what's really
getting usage if you know it's really
going up and what's really going down
then you can plan your 20:19 and go I
should learn that I should stop using
that I should move on so there's three
parts to this talk first
there's gonna be a quick tour of stuff
that you should know about NPM
especially our newer features because
not that information is not perfectly
distributed yet and second I'm gonna
talk about what NPM knows about you who
you are and what kind of tools you use
right now and finally I'm going to make
some predictions about what tools that
you should
in 2019 and where javascript is going to
go in the next couple of years so you
should stick around because you can
watch me be extremely wrong so the first
thing you should know about NPM is that
NPM is extremely popular NPM has more
than 10 million users these days and
they download more than 6 billion
packages every 7 days we think about 85%
of the people who use JavaScript for
anything are already using NPM and it's
gonna hit a hundred percent we don't
think that there's any limit to that and
that's even more amazing because
javascript is by some measure is the
most popular programming language in the
world right now it is the biggest
language on github by a long way and 70%
of people who responded to Stack
Overflow survey said that they use
JavaScript which means that if you
believe those numbers and you could do
the math it's possible that 50% of all
programmers in the world are using NPM
right now regardless of what they do as
a programmer the next thing to know
about NPM is that NPM is being used
everywhere javascript is being used and
javascript is being used everywhere
people are building websites in it
obviously but they're also building
mobile apps they're building desktop
apps they're writing server-side code
they're doing robotics and IOT and
JavaScript and all of these people are
using NPM to do it NPM has become the
package manager for all of JavaScript
but above all NPM is for web developers
93% of people who use NPM say that the
code that they write is used in a
browser at least some of the time that
is a huge shift for NPM NPM came to life
thinking of itself as the node package
manner it manager thought of itself as a
tool for server-side JavaScript and
that's no longer true it is primarily a
tool that people use to put websites
together and in fact 97% of the code in
a modern web app is downloaded from NPM
you as the application developer are
responsible only for the last 3% all of
the interesting parts of your
application the parts that you write are
only three percent of the total
code base in a modern rich web
application the current version of NPM
is NPM six which means that if you are
using NPM three or NPM four which
something like 40% of you are then you
are woefully behind the times and it is
time to upgrade and PM six is twenty
times faster than NPM four was so that
by itself should be enough reason for
you to upgrade and because I said that
NPM is faster now somebody is going to
ask is it faster than yarn the answer is
yes it is faster than yarn or more
accurately all of the package managers
are about the same speed now because
open-source worked the way that
open-source is supposed to work and the
makers of yarn and NPM and P NPM and all
of the other JavaScript package managers
got together and started talking to each
other and sharing code and sharing
expertise and all of the package
managers got a lot faster in the last
two years but as a result they're now
all roughly the same speed because all
of the low-hanging fruit has been taken
away part of how this speed came about
in NPM six is one of the biggest changes
in NPM recently which is that NPM five
and six they lock by default whenever
you install a package lock JSON is
created which means that the packages
that you are using in development are
exactly the same packages that turn upon
production this was yarns biggest
innovation and it became absolutely
essential because of the number of
modules involved the average web
application uses a thousand modules you
need a package lock in that situation
and yarn was correct to notice that and
so we followed their we followed their
example and it was a good idea and pm6
also introduces NPM CI this is an
alternative way of calling NPM for use
in continuous integration environments
and continuous integration environments
there are certain constraints that are
released we know that there's not going
to be a node modules folder we know a
couple other things because it's running
in CI and that means that we can run npm
install in a mode that is twice as fast
as an ordinary install and loses nothing
so if you're using NPM install in your
continuous integration you can just
introduce NPM CI and your builds will
suddenly be twice as fast as they were
before
as NPM has got bigger security has
become an even bigger concern for us
earlier this year
NPM acquired lift security that was new
we've never acquired anybody before and
the first thing that we did was take
their node security platform and
integrated into NPM itself that resulted
in a bunch of new features the first of
which was two-factor off to factor auth
is important for everyone but it's
especially important if you publish
packages if you're a package author you
should be using two-factor off to make
sure that nobody can publish your
packages as you in May we also launched
NPM quick audits you've probably already
seen them if you're running NPM because
they happen every time you install now
you get notices if any of the packages
that you are installing have any known
vulnerabilities this works in nearly
every version of NPM but if you're using
NPM 6 the warnings are more detailed and
the information that you get out of them
is better we do about three and a half
of these quick audits every week and the
stats that we're getting from these
quick audits are a little bit alarming
something like 11 percent of the
packages installed right now have
critical vulnerabilities in them
critical vulnerabilities we don't give
those away like candy those are sort of
stop everything you are going to get
hacked problem and 11 percent of
installs have them in them 37 percent
had a high vulnerability which is still
nothing to sneeze at but fortunately
improving that is easy because running
NPM audit will give you all of will give
you a detailed report of all of the
vulnerabilities in your application and
what to do about them and the good news
is that it's usually pretty easy to fix
the vulnerability in a JavaScript
application because usually the fix
already exists all you have to do is
find the vulnerable package and upgrade
it and that's interesting because the
way that you upgrade it is you run NPM
so if NPM is giving you this advice that
you should run NPM why doesn't MPM just
run NPM and save you that step that's
exactly what NPM does
npm audit fix will automatically follow
the advice that npm audit gives you and
run the upgrades as long as it can
safely do so by safely I mean it's
following semver so it's only going to
bring in patch versions if the fix is in
a braking version then you need to run -
- force to bring in the braking version
obviously NPM isn't going to like
magically solve the halting problem and
promise that your code is going to still
work after we've done this upgrade you
should still be running your tests and
making sure that NPM has left your
software in a working state but it takes
a lot of the grunt work out of keeping
your packages up-to-date and secure this
brings me briefly back to yarn we used
to say that we didn't care which client
people use to access the NPM registry
because open source and open standards
and everything like that but we can no
longer say that with a straight face
after NPM caught up to yarn in terms of
speed and with the addition of two FA
and NPM audits NPM is now safer than a
yarn and if it's safer then you should
be using NPM like it's a huge shocker
obviously that NPM recommends you should
use NPM but we do these links are to a
blog posts from a company that switched
to yarn and then switched back and a
tool that they built that allows them to
switch from yarn back to NPM one more
big recent change with NPM that I should
mention is that we shut down our github
issue tracker we still use github for
the code itself but NPM is one of the
world's largest open source projects and
the issue tracker was just not scaling
to meet our needs so now we have a
discourse at NPM community which is a
URL because this is 2018 it's a sort of
combination of an issue tracker in the
forum where you can get help with your
issues and your calls also track bug
fixes and you can track new features as
they get developed and the last thing to
know about NPM because and I keep
including it because people keep asking
this question is so how does that make
money are you a charity or something
buck no we are a company the registry
costs millions of dollars a year to run
and we earn those millions of dollars by
producing services that NPM developers
NPM users love like private package
hosting and now security services as
well
you should really look into them because
the registry costs millions of dollars
to run so let's move on to what NPM
knows about you first off how do I know
all of this stuff well there's two ways
first you're all constantly downloading
stuff from NPM so we can tell what
you're downloading we can tell you if
you're downloading more of it or you're
downloading less of it
and secondly we asked you we ran a
survey at the beginning of this year of
sixteen thousand NPM users and we asked
them directly what it is that you're up
to and the results were fascinating but
first I want to try a party trick and I
have no idea if this is going to work if
everybody could stand up I'm gonna make
if you can't stand up just raise a hand
or something I'm gonna make a series of
statements about you and if the
statement isn't true you can sit back
down so stay standing if you use NPM
stay standing if you write JavaScript
for browsers you write JavaScript at
work you're concerned that maybe the
open source code you use isn't always
secure some of you are lying you mostly
taught yourself JavaScript in addition
to JavaScript you also write PHP or Java
sometimes I'm gonna start losing people
fast now you work at a company that
isn't really considered a tech company
you started using NPM less than two
years ago you're using webpack and Babel
you're writing a react app using
typescript my god I got all the way to
the end and there are still people
standing this is how much NPM knows
about you thank you very much
but that was all really fast let's go
back to a couple of those because those
are really interesting the first one
that's interesting to dig into is that
not everybody who is writing stuff with
NPM considers themselves a JavaScript
developer 30% of you are writing Java or
PHP or Python and tend to consider
yourselves primarily those kinds of
developers c-sharp is also pretty
popular and go and C++ and Ruby are in
there and it should and maybe it was
surprising that a lot of NPM users don't
consider themselves JavaScript
developers but it probably shouldn't
have been there's a guy at UC Berkeley
called Leo Maravich who did a study of
what makes people pick a programming
language is it because they like it is
it because it's performant is it because
of the language features is it because
it's familiar he discovered that the
dominant reason that people pick a
programming language is the availability
of open source libraries in that
language whether or not they like the
language if there's a library that lets
them get [ __ ] done they will pick that
language to do it in and that is exactly
what you said when we asked you people
say they pick JavaScript because of the
libraries available another way of
putting that is people pick JavaScript
because of NPM there were a bunch of
other reasons that people mentioned
about why they picked JavaScript
including a sad 15% who said that they
didn't get to choose whether they use
JavaScript interestingly this group was
almost exclusively Ruby developers
another important finding was how big a
concern to most people's security of
open source JavaScript was 77% of people
said that they are concerned about the
security of their open source JavaScript
and more concerning lis 52% of people
said that the tools to do to check that
open source JavaScript is secure and
reliable were not good enough I talked
about all the security features that
we've been adding this is the data that
made us do that we looked at what you
said and you were like holy [ __ ] it
needs to be more secure so we built a
bunch of security features and we bought
a security company so now would be a
good time to mention NPM Enterprise if
you're a big company and you're worried
about the security of your job open
source JavaScript well first off good
call it's scary out there and secondly
we can help you with that
NPM enterprise service will give you
your own registry domain that allows you
to completely control what Travis crypt
makes it into your network it'll give
you security alerts and ton of other
great security features and I promise
this is the last paid plug for our
wonderful delightful paid features so
that's a little about and who we are as
NPM users but what I promised you
was information about what tools you can
use or what tools you might want to use
in 2019 and to do that we need to look
at what tools you're using right now the
thing about developers when you tell
them about what tools are getting
unpopular and more popular is that they
get really passionate about their tools
and if I tell somebody that the tool
that they love is getting less popular
they tend to get really defensive and
kind of rude on Twitter and all I'm
saying is that these are the numbers
that we're seeing we could be wrong
these things are going up these things
are going down I don't have a dog in
this fight I'm not here to tell you that
your framework is a piece of [ __ ] I'm
here to tell you that the numbers are
going down if you want me to tell you
that your framework is a piece of [ __ ]
that is what the pool party is for
afterwards
so before I show you a bunch of angry
making graphs I need you to get
something into your head which is this
is how the registry grows it grows 10%
month on month every month for years
this is extremely difficult to get a
human brain around the registry has
grown 14,000 percent since 2014 the fact
that the registry is growing so
ridiculously fast means that new users
are constantly showing up in fact as I
was showing you earlier when you were
standing up and sitting down 51 percent
of NPM users have been using it for less
than two years that means that
everything in the registry always has
more users everyone's graph is going up
into the right even the shittiest
packages are constantly acquiring new
users just because there's so many
people showing up and trying out new
stuff so look at the blind at the top of
this graph that is Express Express is
bedrock to NPM practically everyone who
uses NPM uses Express eventually here's
a graph of the Express downloads as a
share of the registry this is the metric
we're going to use for the rest of these
graphs this is not how absolutely
popular Express is and Express is
acquiring users incredibly quickly this
is how popular it is relative to
everything else in the registry and read
so Xpress used to be 1.5% of the
registry all by itself now Express is
0.1% of the registry 0.1% of the
registry is enormous ly popular 0.1% of
the registry is 4.8 million downloads a
week it is staggeringly popular it's
just less relatively popular than it was
before and all of these graphs are gonna
use this strange and slightly confusing
but very revealing metric so let's first
take a look at some front-end frameworks
starting with backbone as you can see
back in 2013 backbone was the [ __ ] it
was almost as popular as Express but now
basically nobody uses backbone and by
basically nobody I mean 250,000
downloads a week
the thing that you can see with the
backbone graph better than any other
framework any other graph is the pattern
of how a framework dies people do not
switch horses midstream they do not
change what framework a project is
written in after the project has started
they continue to maintain old projects
and they start new projects in the new
framework and they slowly retire old
pieces of software written in old
frameworks so framework usage never
falls off a cliff it has this long slow
decay because nobody's reading new
projects in backbone these days it's
safe to say what's happening is that a
lot of people are maintaining legacy
applications written in backbone written
raise your hand if that's you write two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
week so now let's take a look at react
react is goddamn running away with the
web 60% of people who use NPM report
that they are using react at least some
of the time and I told you there were 10
million of you so that means there are 6
million developers working in react
these days that is huge usage and really
impressive growth considering how big it
already is but it's no longer runaway
growth if you look at that graph it
seems to be sort of may be slowing down
we're gonna look at that a little bit
later to see what's going on there but
first we're gonna look at angular
angular is an extremely popular
framework when I get that out of the way
in our survey in January about 40% of
our users said that they used angular
which is to say about 2/3 as many as use
react but our downloads data says
something a bit different now downloads
data says about half as many people to
use angular the angular community was
very quick to point out this discrepancy
and to yell at me angrily on Twitter
about why that might be so I'm not going
to say that angular is getting less
popular
I don't have enough data to be sure that
angular is getting less popular what I
do know is that angular is seeing fewer
downloads than it used to and the
Downloads peaked in 2017 and are now in
a pattern of slow decline ember is an
unusual story ember was pretty popular
in 2015 and then it went through a sort
of rough patch but in 2017 and 2018 it's
making a comeback this is really unusual
I've never seen a framework bounce back
before but now amber is seeing really
healthy growth in January about 4% of
NPM users said that they were using
ember and you could expect that number
to be about twice as big now roughly as
popular as ember is view but view is a
different growth story view is just
taking off like a rocket right now if I
had to guess why Reax growth appears to
be slowing down I would say that it is
because new users are adopting view and
the ones who aren't adopting view are
probably adopting ember I don't have a
perfect picture I could still be wrong
about this there are a zillion other
frameworks that might be contributing
but that's what it looks like to me
right now I want to dig a little bit
deeper into the Reax ecosystem partly
because so many of you are using it and
partly because it's unique react isn't
really a framework react is a solution
to one part of the web development
problem specifically react as a way of
making components that share state and
there are lots of types of applications
where sharing where being able to use
Rios reusable components that share
state is useful so rich web apps
obviously but also mobile apps and
desktop apps but rich web apps have
another requirement which is they need
to be able to map URLs to state in the
application to be able to do that you
need to use react router or some other
kind of plug-in router much like react
itself react router grew quickly and
that has now leveled off but as you see
it's leveled off at about half the level
of popularity of react itself and that's
really interesting because it's one of
the triumphs of react as a piece of
technology it's part of why react is so
popular they managed to successfully
decouple these functions every framework
that I was aware of prior to react was a
sort of kitchen sink framework they had
own component model their own router
their own data model their own
everything reacts only has a component
model and by letting people choose their
own solutions for the router and the
data model and everything else it has
created a more flexible design and that
means that it's getting greater adoption
simply because it's adopting - it's
adapting to more use cases so react is
more than twice as popular as a react
router because there are lots of
applications that use routers other than
react router and there are also lots of
react applications that don't need a
router at all like mobile apps and
desktop apps
so speaking of reacts decoupled model
let's look at flux flux was introduced
by Facebook at roughly the same time as
react and it was coupled with graph QL
flux was how Facebook expected that you
would manage state in large web
applications and as you can see that
didn't happen at all
imagine if Facebook had coupled these
together imagine if you couldn't use
react without using flux at the same
time fluxes unpopularity would have
dragged react down with it and that
isn't what happened instead what
happened is react took off and people
use Redux instead to manage their state
as you can see fluxes downturn coincides
exactly with the introduction of Redux
as soon as Redux became available people
abandoned flux our mass then Redux and
Redux router
Redux and react router track each other
they are very popular combination
they're almost always used at the same
time I mentioned graph QL earlier graph
QL started in react land and has now
expanded beyond it and it is red hot
right now there are two big libraries
for using graph QL on the browser one is
Apollo and one is real a but as you can
see Apollo is the one that's really
running away with it right now so far
I've spent a lot of time focused on
front-end and that is because that's
what NPM users mostly are but 70% of you
are also writing server-side
applications
so what frameworks are people using on
the on the server side well they're
using a whole lot of Express in fact
relative to Express nothing else even
shows up so what if we take Express out
of the picture what does it look like in
blue is Khoa KO is a sort of spiritual
successor to Express
Co is relative popularity is pretty flat
but keep in mind that
flat relative popularity means that koa
grew 14,000 percent so ko is doing
really well and this is why share of
registry is this useful but confusing
metric sales is as the name suggests a
straight up quart of Ruby on Rails to
node and as the graph suggests that
seemed like a good idea at the time
happy is a framework that NPM used to
use on our own site we switched earlier
this year to using react instead
happiest relative growth is also pretty
flat which again means 14,000 percent
growth pretty healthy and then there's
next jeaious which is from site next
jeaious is a sort of all in kitchen sink
framework but it uses react for its
component model so if you like react but
you don't have to make all of these
pain-in-the-ass decisions about routers
and tooling and all of that other stuff
you just you know fire up a next
application and you get a react app
without having to think too hard about
it I think that I personally think
that's pretty cool and people seem to
agree with me because in red in relative
terms it is growing really really fast
so how are we doing so far
for the next part of this talk I need to
split the room into two pieces so
everybody on this side of the line is
team a everybody on this side of the
line is team B let's hear it from team a
team B team a again team B again
fantastic I'm not gonna use that for
anything it's just to wake you up after
20 minutes of grass so we've talked
about frameworks
[Applause]
we've talked about frameworks a lot but
a big part of what people use NPM for is
tooling to helping their boo chain and
their tooling and everything else we
have fantastic data here the first of
that data is that people want less
tooling people hate tooling they would
like to not use any tooling at all
please could we just burn it all down
and have it built in that would be great
but to be able to do that we need to
know what tooling it is that we're using
in the first place so 85% of us use web
frameworks unsurprisingly that compares
to the 93 percent of us who are writing
web apps which means that eight percent
of us are rolling our own dare god
seventy four percent of us are using
transpilers 69 percent are using linters
sixty seven percent are using bundlers
and 80% of those are using webpack 58
percent of us are using CSS
preprocessors and 58 percent are using
testing frameworks there's a couple of
those that I want to dig into a little
bit more transpilers are tools to
translate other languages into
JavaScript and the most popular one is
obviously bable bable translates mostly
JavaScript into other flavors of
JavaScript with one big exception which
is JSX which isn't really part of
JavaScript but at this point given the
massive adoption of reacts and how many
people who write JavaScript are writing
JSX we should probably reconsider that
we should probably be thinking about how
JSX becomes a first-class part of
javascript if it's that popular
CoffeeScript is still in there an
element closure script have small
followings but the really big surprise
here is typescript 46% of us are writing
typescript who knew that well 46% of you
I guess
typescript is mostly JavaScript it just
adds types there was a talk about it too
talks ago and types are just a sort of
form of built-in testing that allows
large teams to scale up by making things
a little bit safer Microsoft launched
typescript with its own package manager
but the community sort of rebelled and
was like we hate using to package
managers let's just use NPM and to their
credit they did Microsoft switched types
into using NPM is their main reg
three which is very new Microsoft of
them and they did it without asking us
if that was okay which is very old
Microsoft of that linters as 70% of you
know linters are tools that tell you if
your code is nice they will check for
obvious errors they will you know fix
your syntax for you they will add a
style guide if that's what you want
they're super popular and by far the
most popular of them is es lint and you
may have heard about es lint recently
because there was a security incident
involving the eslint yes like most
open-source is maintained by a team of
volunteers and those team of that team
of volunteers are mostly experienced
developers who know what they're doing
but unfortunately one of them was being
a little bit lazy and he hadn't turned
on two-factor off for his account on npm
and to make matters worse he was using a
password that he'd used on another
website that other website was
compromised the password was stolen and
long story short somebody got that
password and used it on NPM and got
access to his account what that attacker
then did was published a new version of
es lint and that version of es lint had
a credentials harvester in it if you
download and installed es lint that day
you're NPM login tokens would be
transmitted back up to the Internet and
stolen this could have been a disaster
this is the kind of thing it keeps us up
at night it would have been possible to
take those stolen tokens to hijack other
packages to publish a compromised
versions of them hijack more people
suddenly you have a huge huge problem
but what happened instead is that people
noticed really quickly because there's
10 million of you and you're all
developers within 30 minutes of people
noticing we had put an advisory up and
taken down the offending package and NPM
audit was warning anybody who installed
the bad version of the package that it
was bad
and then we reset the login tokens of
all 10 million unpaid users in case any
of those tokens had been stolen and as
far as we can tell it's been a couple of
weeks now it worked nobody else's tokens
were used and no other packages seem to
have been compromised so far and we had
a bunch of third parties double-check
our work on that one but this is why NPM
is taking security system
because with ten million users the very
small percentage of users who are bad is
still a very large absolute number of
people so you have to use two factor
auth it is now possible to enforce
two-factor off on a package so that the
es Ihnen team for instance can enforce
that nobody is able to publish a copy of
es lint unless they have used two-factor
off to do so and you should use NPM six
because it will warn you about these
things so now back to our tooling stats
I mentioned testing frameworks testing
for of great deal of you are using mocha
Jasmine is also very popular gest is
extremely popular which is unsurprising
given its connection to react and how
popular react is but sitting up there at
number three is none come on
21% of you can't be bothered to write
any tests at all surely you can do
better and the fun part is I know that
you can do better and in fact I know
that you will do better because the data
told me that you would we first noticed
this effect when we were looking at
security and we were building our
security features we looked into how
developers approach security and we
split them up by how much experience
they had and we discovered this really
clear linear progression the more
experience you have writing javascript
the more seriously you take your
security we discovered that this was
true for nearly everything considered a
best practice these bars are comparing
just the most experienced group the ten
plus years group to the least
experienced group the less than one year
group and in every single case the same
linear progression happened there was in
bundling linting security steps like
code reviews and audits and code
scanning they all get more popular the
more experienced you are so I know that
you'll do better because the more time
you spend doing this the more likely you
are to do this stuff in particular we
noticed this effect in security in the
least-experienced group only about 58
percent of people use any security tools
at all but in the most experienced group
eighty-five percent of people do and the
good news is that you can get into the
eighty-five percent group just by
upgrading to NPM six because you'll get
automatic scans this again was the data
that made us build that feature we
didn't just build it for no reason we
because 16,000 people said could you
build this feature already so we did so
now we come to the future of Java
scripts this is the part where I must
make some bad predictions and you get to
take pictures of me standing in front of
slides where I make bad predictions so
when the predictions turn out to be bad
you can make fun of me with this big
picture where I say something that's
obviously wrong so let's begin the
biggest prediction that I can make is
that nothing and most likely to be
accurate is that nothing lasts forever
backbone was once the dominant framework
and it is now an afterthought jQuery
which revolutionized web development
pour one out for jQuery it's not
relevant anymore it's been superseded
any framework or tool has a heyday that
is measured in a handful of years and
then a long slow lingering death so
don't cling too tightly to your tools
you should expect five years from now
that your tools will have rolled over
because that's about how long that's
about as long as they live on the
front-end frameworks side it would be
unwise to bet against Reax at least for
the next few years react has a ton of
users but possibly more importantly
react has a ton of modules
the reason reacts having lots of modules
is important is because as I mentioned
before the reason people choose
libraries is we choose languages is
because of the availability of libraries
people put up with all of this pain in
the ass tooling in JavaScript that they
tell us that they hate because NPM has
seven hundred and seventy thousand
packages in it and that huge pile of
delicious delicious libraries keeps
everybody coming back even though it's
kind of a pain in the ass to do so reiax
might be able to pull off the same trick
and if it does it's going to be
unstoppable
there are react components that you can
npm install if you npm install react
color you get a color picker in your web
app you don't have to do anything other
than drop a tag into your web app to use
it that my friends has been the dream of
web development for a long time and
react is the first time i've really seen
it work will react become the UI library
for the web will react components become
the way that we put websites together
and will stop building things from
scratch and just dump a bunch of
components in
at webapp it is too soon to know but it
could do it's too soon to predict that
because as we said react is kind of
slowing down is it view that's causing
that is an ember that's causing that or
maybe it's just that react while very
very flexible more flexible in any web
framework has ever been before is still
not flexible enough to cover 100% of web
development use cases it could be that
no framework can ever win no framework
can ever be the single framework that
every web app is built-in in fact that's
a pretty safe guess but not a terribly
useful one if you're trying to decide
what to use so I would say in the
meantime you should probably bet on
react react has the users and the number
of users you have is a big deal when it
comes to picking a framework because you
want to be where everybody else is you
want them to write the tutorials you
want them to find the bugs you want them
to answer your questions on Stack
Overflow for you and for that react is
the safest bed right now if you don't
like react there are a couple of good
reasons to pick other things angular has
the support of Google and since Google
isn't going anywhere
angular isn't going anywhere view has
the momentum and it is definitely the
new hotness right now and keep an eye on
next Jas because it's the power of react
with a lot more convenience and I think
that has a lot of power and as I said
amber has a bit of everything it has
lots of users it has good corporate
support and it's got some new momentum
in 2019 if you're looking for something
new to learn if you're looking for sense
to really get your head around for the
first time graph QL is the thing that it
should be graph QL is about to be huge
there are whole startups built around
providing services for graph QL the
tooling around it is getting better and
it has some real advantages if you are
building server-side api's or you are
consuming server-side api's you should
look into weather graph QL can help you
do that better and when it comes to
bundling transpiling and linting i can
safely predict that if you don't already
you will start doing these things the
data says that as you gain experience
you will pick these up webpack is 80% of
bundling and it seems like a safe bet
for a while
es lint will almost certainly stay the
most popular linter and babble will
remain the transpiler
choice but don't forget about typescript
46% of you are already using typescript
and that's still surprising to me even
though I've been staring in this data
for months so the biggest prediction of
this talk may be that you will stop
writing JavaScript and start writing
typescript instead an obvious question
that comes out of that prediction is
what happens to NPM if everybody stops
writing javascript and start starting
typescript instead and the answer is
nothing and the way that I know that is
because it already happened and you
didn't even notice a big percentage of
the modules on NPM right now are native
code there see they compile when you
install them and you use them in
JavaScript without even noticing that
you are using a pile of see even more
packages are written in es6 which is
JavaScript but not the JavaScript you
can actually use a new browser
everything just gets transpiled before
it goes to the before it goes to the
browser all of react is written in es6
which is a version of javascript that
doesn't really exist yet and you didn't
notice react just happened and you
didn't have to care about the fact that
it's written in this imaginary version
of javascript there are tons of packages
written in CoffeeScript sand type
scripts and a whole bunch of other
languages and you've not noticed that
any of them are there and that is great
that interoperability is amazing one of
the most exciting developments on this
front is wisdom
that's webassembly to you and me whether
simply lets you write in any language
any compiled language and turn it into
java scripts but unlike transpile
javascript it runs as fast as native
code you can get desktop like
performance in the browser using wasm to
compile native code that's a really
really interesting idea it provides a
way to give web apps really amazing
performance for computationally
expensive tasks and the best part of it
is that it's already here and again you
didn't notice woz impac is a tool from
mozilla that lets you write code in rust
and then publish it to npm just like any
other javascript package and use it from
javascript without noticing in fact that
seems like it's already leaking its way
into the registry so whaza might already
be in your stack without you noticing
and that brings me to my other big
prediction which is no matter what
happens npm is here to stay
whether javascript stays big or whether
web development becomes writing a bunch
of application
in rust the huge pile of delicious
delicious packages is going to keep us
coming back to npm for a long time
NPM might one day be a registry that's
not full of Java scripts but it will
still be the way that you put websites
together I've been doing web development
now for 22 years and it has always
thrilled me and no less so than right
now the stuff that we can do on the web
is amazing and wonderful and scary and
the tools that we use to make it are ad
hoc and broken and partially fixed and
my final prediction is that that's the
way it's always gonna be we remake the
web's so quickly that the tools are
never gonna be done it's never gonna be
finished it's never gonna be a perfect
story and that is how you know that the
web is growing that's why the web has
managed to stay so vibrant for so long
because it reinvents itself every five
years
I find that tremendously exciting I hope
you find it tremendously exciting and I
hope you all stick around for the next
22 years to see what happens
thank you very much
you